we begin in the U.S where days after the
U.S midterm elections control of
Congress is still up in the air Democrat
Mark Kelly won re-election in a key
Senate race in Arizona he defeated the
trump-backed venture capitalist Blake
Masters who has yet to concede Democrats
and Republicans now have 49 seats each
in the upper house of Congress control
will come down to the results in Nevada
or Georgia which is going to a runoff in
December
and for more on that let's bring in DW
correspondent Sumi sumascanda who joins
us from Washington D.C so assuming how
important is this win for the Democrats
and U.S President Joe Biden
it's pretty important Aaron I mean it
puts Democrats as you said one seat away
from extending that majority that they
have in the senate for another two years
and Arizona as a state really has been
key to Democrat Senate majority I mean
if you remember in 2020 President Biden
just narrowly won the state it was key
to his victory it is a hotly contested
State there were big campaigns we saw on
both sides of the aisle to really
energize voters for example Latino
voters who were a big part of the
electorate there it wasn't unexpected so
the Democrat Mark Kelly was favored
heading to this election and he had
opened up a decent lead over his
opponent but what it means now going
forward is that there's going to be all
the more scrutiny on what comes out of
Nevada that is the other swing state
where vote counting is still taking
place and the Democrat there is behind
at the moment by around a thousand votes
and of course Aaron Georgia as well
where we're going to see a runoff
between the Republican and Democrat
candidates for Senate on December 6. so
a lot still hanging in the balance
all right so Mark Kelly defeated a
candidate backed by former president
Donald Trump and we saw actually many
trump-backed candidates doing poorly in
uh this year's polling does that mean
that the Trump brand may be running out
of steam
well I think you know we have to talk
about the former president and what he's
been facing this past week I mean it
hasn't been the best week for him many
of his endorsed candidates as you said
um like Blake Masters in Arizona Dr Oz
in Pennsylvania they lost and we're
actually seeing right-wing media
questioning the former president's uh
hold over the party so Fox News here has
been bringing on guests who are openly
calling for the former president to move
on he is not happy about any of this
he's expected to announce next week that
he's running again for president and uh
he's been lashing out on his social
media platform truth social but you know
the former president has been counted
out before so I think it really is too
soon to say and just a quick note um
Aaron also you know he has actually
started a brand of conservative populism
that has become this hard right movement
that is still very influential in the
Republican Party he's energized a part
of the electorate that previously didn't
really vote for the Republican party
with the fervor that it does now so he's
Unleashed something among Core group of
supporters and people running for office
that certainly isn't going away oh
you're definitely right it doesn't seem
that they're gonna be going away anytime
soon but what do these midterm results
mean for the upcoming presidential race
in 2024
well we're starting to see some of those
chips fall so as I said we're likely
going to find out very soon if the
former president uh Donald Trump is
going to run I believe he will that he
will make that announcement Tuesday of
next week and Joe Biden the current
president he feels validated Vindicated
by these election results so that means
that he is more likely to run he says he
intends to but is going to consult his
family and and the party and he's going
to make a decision by early next year so
I think the two parties Aaron are going
to be taking notes and breaking down all
the numbers looking at who voted for
whom and and where
and trying to figure out what the best
path is to victory in two years time but
again so much can change in two years
yeah it really does seem like the race
is anything but decided at this point
all right that was DW correspondence
reporting for us from Washington thank
you for your analysis